Coffee be ready just over there thanks
man hey bud
what can I get for you okay I get a
medium coffee to go medium coffee got it
named Zach Zach Zach attack hey Justin
can I get a medium brew from a Maine bro
Zach attack attack attack Zach attack I
like that all right Zach Zach Zach
attack Zach attack Zach attack hello mr.
president
yeah the world is under a Zach attack
hey everybody attention please put your
coffees down laptops closed let's give
it up for my main man whose torture I
mean they all started chanting Zach
attack I feel like a freakin
six-year-old
yeah the life of a white straight male
is so hard I actually don't think it's
that bad of a [ __ ] look you guys don't
get it you all have amazing nicknames
ser bear meals on wheels
yo Gabby Gabby I just want to be called
Zach just plain Zach is that too much to
ask for damn it okay you know what
first thing tomorrow I'm gonna go in
there and I'm gonna tell the barista
what's white no one is ever gonna call
me Zach attack ever again honey that is
so sweet of you thank you I mean just
think about it okay some lonely tech
worker same routine every single morning
he goes to work he works he punches and
punches out but then I thought you blew
his mind shove it up a little bit I did
some collar into his life send some
straight back to childhood you know what
I did
Thank You famous Fight Club you're so
[ __ ] hot right now no you are did you
see him tomorrow maybe no maybe not
hey who wouldn't want to get Zach
attacked again oh he will don't worry he
will what do you mean well you know how
sometimes I stay late to use the word
computer uh-huh I knew that just one
Zach attack wasn't gonna be enough to
tame Jack's boring life around
I hacked into the California government
database and I legally changed his name
to Zach attack his driver's license yeah
birth certificate tax identification and
all the federal stuff so that's not even
the end of it so I did a little more
hacking and I realized that reality
itself is just a simulation that's run
entirely out of the coffee shop backroom
computer
consciousness is just a stream of
electrons that exists in a computer and
a virtual coffee shop yes ABI yes
everything is the feeling of the sun's
warmth as it rains across your face the
joy holding your newborn child all just
binary bits of information being
processed on what I assume to be is an
interdimensional quantum computer cool I
have access to alter anything in our
world yes and rolled over my stupid
resurrect lost loved one I had the power
to end human suffering forever so what
did you do I did the only logical thing
a man in my position could do I changed
every instance of Zach's name to Zach
attack in this universe and every
alternate universe past present future
wow that is so selfless
I know do you think it changed anything
else and gonna get your name yeah it's
Zach attack got it Zach no no Zach
attack there's an attack at the end not
not exactly socket ugh what is up Vaughn
cappuccino please for a life in a Hitler
all right Heather
that'll be anything uh yeah this always
happens it's Hitler says an age I TL we
oughta know he does there's only one age
Zach attack